bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans Ça vous
regarde on est en direct et notre grand
témoin ce soir c'est le dessinateur
Gilles bonsoir Jules quelle rentrée en
feu d'artifice un nouvel album de Lucky
Luke on va en parler une nouvelle saison
de 50 nuances de Grey sur Arte s'il vous
plaît et puis et puis un roman
feuilleton au seuil sur la mythologie
pour raconter l'époque on va y revenir
dans le détail on est ensemble pendant
une heure pour décrypter l'actualité de
ce vendredi 13 janvier et l'actualité ce
soir cette partie socialiste et oui le
Parti socialiste c'est l'heure de vérité
pour l'EPS qui doit trancher sur sa
ligne on va revenir sur les premières
tendances du Congrès stratégie
d'alliance avec les insoumis c'est le
principal en jeu alors peut-il survivre
ce PS au moment où le parti Jean-Luc
Mélenchon traverse une crise on en débat
dans un instant avec nos invités puis
aux alentours de 20h15 seront les partis
pris de nos affranchis et le bourbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée vous êtes prêts
ça marche
[Musique]
il joue son avenir mais aussi celui de
l'Union à gauche entre socialiste et
mélange sioniste la motion d'Olivier
fort devrait être arrivé en tête ça
c'est sûr en tête du Congrès mais on n'a
pas encore les résultats officiels parce
qu'on est enregistré comme chaque
vendredi on va parler du congrès du PS
ce soir donc rien n'est joué pour le
deuxième tour petite bataille en
apparence mais grande conséquences sur
le paysage politique à gauche bonsoir
Emma raphovitz merci d'être avec nous
Raffo vite pardonnez-moi vous êtes l'un
des nouveaux visages du Parti socialiste
la nouvelle génération vous avez 27 ans
et vous présidez les jeunes socialistes
vous êtes à fond derrière Olivier Faure
on peut dire ça Olivier Faure artisan de
la nuque bien sûr bonsoir Pascal
Perrineau bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver
professeur à Sciences Po Paris
polytologue bonsoir Gaspard Gantzer
merci d'être avec nous ancien directeur
de la communication de François Hollande
êtes-vous encore de gauche c'est
la question quand même que vous vous
posiez à vous et à vos lecteurs dans
votre dernier livre chez Flammarion dans
la police de la chute du PS Marie
Benedict Dallaire bonsoir bonsoir grande
connaisseuse du PS que vous suivez
depuis longtemps vous êtes journaliste
politique à RTL et puis à distance avec
nous ce soir Lamia et la rage bonsoir
l'AMIA et la rage porte-parole du Parti
socialiste adjointe à la mairie de Paris
vous vous soutenez Nicolas maillet
Rossignol le maire de Rouen qui affronte
donc Olivier Faure dans ce dans ce
congrès Jules vous adorez la politique
ça j'en suis sûr et un peu ma matière
première depuis très longtemps vous êtes
évidemment invité à intervenir dans ce
débat quand vous le souhaitez on a
évidemment besoin de planter le décor
parce qu'on suit pas le PS au quotidien
qui sont les candidats à ton des
premiers résultats les enjeux de ce
congrès du PS le tout en deux ans en
seconde s'il vous plaît c'est le chrono
de Blacko tout de suite
Stéphane bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam
bonsoir Jul bonsoir à toutes et à tous
voilà c'est fait alors les enjeux de ce
congrès salut Myriam moi je me souviens
d'une époque où le congrès du PS mais
c'était un évènement qui faisait de la
une de la politique à chaque fois
souvenez-vous des duels mythiques
Mitterrand requin à Metz 179 le congrès
de Rennes fabule Jospin même le congrès
de Reims le combat des deux femmes
royales contre Aubry à chaque fois ça
faisait la Une du journal sauf que là
aujourd'hui je sais pas l'intérêt est un
porte tombé non mais regardez la une du
monde notre journal de référence en tout
cas du soir voilà daterir donc publié
aujourd'hui pouvez chercher pas la
moindre allusion même pas la peine
de Lens a plus d'importance que le
résultat du premier tour du vote pour
désigner donc le patron du PS en même
temps faut comprendre le monde on suit
un peu le centre d'intérêt de ses
lecteurs et regarder où on en est du
nombre d'adhérents eprs donc vous voyez
ça a quand même baissé depuis 2006 ça a
été divisé par cette le nombre
d'adhérents ils ont plus que 41 000 et
en plus il y en a que 22000 qui hier
soir ce sont pas déplacés mais on
participait au vote donc comme
manifestement la passion n'est pas
totale pour cette élection faut être
résumé où on en est il y a donc trois
candidats qui chacun présente ce qu'on
appelait avant une motion qui maintenant
s'appelle un texte d'orientation donc le
texte d'orientation c'est Hélène
Geoffroy qui est maire de Vaulx-en-Velin
elles son idée c'est qu'il faut arrêter
cette alliance avec la nupes on en veut
plus on reprend notre indépendance Théo
2 donc vous le reconnaissez c'est
peut-être le plus connu c'est à coup sûr
le plus connu Olivier fort qui lui veut
rester dans l'alliance de la nupes et
puis le TO3 qui est donc Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol un peu l'invité surprise qui
lui est un peu entre les deux il veut de
l'union de la gauche mais pas forcément
avec les insoumis donc là maintenant on
a bien clarifié les choses il reste plus
qu'à mettre le score en face de chaque
candidat sauf qu'on peut pas le faire on
est quand même là on enregistre
exceptionnellement à 16h on est donc 18h
après le scrutin on ne connaît pas le
résultat précis on a un ordié 50% en
gros pour Olivier fort 30% en gros pour
Nicolas Mayer et 20% pour Hélène
Geoffroy mais les gens se disputent sur
est-ce qu'il a fait plus ou moins que
50% Olivier fort chacun son analyse donc
Olivier Faure lui bien sûr dit j'ai fait
plus de 50% en tweet dans ces cas-là
donc le débat est tranché c'est moi le
patron autre opinion chez les Geoffroy
pas du tout Olivier fort n'a pas franchi
cette fameuse barre des 50% du coup bah
forcément il est minoritaire et puis
cette position un peu nuancée qu'on
apprend à découvrir de
rossignol qui dit que non il y a pas de
majorité mais il dit pas qu'il est
minoritaire dit ah il n'est pas
majoritaire
donc voilà à peu près où où on en est
donc forcément il y a une un comité qui
se réunit pour essayer de faire le tri
là-dessus pour savoir quel est le vrai
résultat donc ça rappelle un peu
justement la belle époque ça rappelle je
sais pas vous souvenez vous congrès de
Reims 2008 le bouquin de automne Antonin
André Karim qui révélait que il y avait
eu grosse triche au Congrès on en est
pas là mais comme ça c'est des des
souvenirs qui reviennent en tout cas
le second tour n'est pas le patron n'est
pas désigné il opposera au second tour
donc Nicolas meilleur Rossignol et
Olivier Favre on verra lequel des deux
lampes c'est compliqué hein je vous
laisse débattre moi je me demande si
c'est pas plus simple de faire comme
chez les insoumis on désigne le patron
sans consulter les militants et
forcément il y a moins de problèmes
c'est sûr c'est sûr ça peut être
efficace on va faire un peu de pédagogie
si vous jouez bien je vais d'abord voir
les observateurs puis j'irai voir les
politiques après Marie Bénédicte a l'air
41000 adhérents au PS la moitié
seulement qui vote est-ce qu'on peut
dire que l'enjeu principal c'est pour ou
contre l'alliance avec Mélenchon bah
clairement c'est c'est comme ça que ça a
été défini oui parce que
Olivier fort qui l'a négocié lui
évidemment il est vraiment sur cette
ligne Hélène Geoffroy en revanche était
totalement contre et elle a dit moi si
je gagne je sortirai de la nuque et puis
effectivement Nicolas Mayer Rossignol a
emprunter une voix médiane c'est-à-dire
il dit bah toute façon dans nos
collectivités on est allié la gauche
donc on va pas sortir de la nuque mais
en même temps là dans la configuration
actuelle on n'existe pas assez le PS
donc il faut qu'on n'existe plus et
qu'on n'entende plus notre voix c'est la
synthèse dans les trois mois
pour comprendre comment on veut bien la
nuque mais pas comme ça voilà
il faut comprendre donc là on est sur
des textes orientation
ça va figer le parti d'une certaine
façon et la semaine prochaine c'est
c'est les responsables c'est les
dirigeants du parti qui se fait en
plusieurs plusieurs actes de tours mais
c'est pas réellement c'est pas vraiment
de tour en fait là effectivement les
militants votés sur sur l'orientation
et la semaine prochaine ils vont voter
sur le nom du premier secrétaire et
c'est les deux premiers textes fallait
textes arrivés en les deux textes
arrivés en tête donc Olivier Faure et
Nicolas Mayer Rossignol il faut rappeler
qu'ils se déplace physiquement les
militants donc quand on dit il y en a
que la moitié qui ont voté il y a aussi
cette donnée là à prendre en compte et
enfin quand même 40 000 militants 20000
qui se déplacent pour voter il est il
est quoi il est cassé il est
moribondez tout à l'heure le peu
d'intérêt ou même l'absence d'intérêt
que le grand journal du soir qui est le
monde porte à ce congrès on a
l'impression que cette espèce d'asthénie
touche également les militants
socialistes les adhérents parce qu'ils
sont tout de même certes ils ont choisi
des modalités de vote d'ailleurs très
étrange quand on est dans la situation
dans laquelle on est aujourd'hui et
qu'on est socialiste on devrait penser à
des modes de consultation qui favorisent
un peu plus la participation la fracture
du PS aujourd'hui
une fracture du Parti socialiste avec
son électorat tout de même faut rappeler
1,7 au dernier élection présidentielle
même pas 700000 français qui ont choisi
le vote en faveur Dani dalgo le Parti
socialiste n'avait jamais connu cela
dans son histoire donc il y a de fait
une rupture entre le Parti socialiste et
son électorat qui est parti voir
ailleurs mais sur les deux grandes
lignes c'est à dire sur les deux grandes
lignes avec on parle d'une Mélenchon
l'union de la gauche mais c'est une
plaisanterie l'union de la gauche ça n'a
jamais été cela l'union de la gauche
c'est ce qui est pratiqué en 1936 c'est
ce qui est pratiqué dans les années 70
c'est-à-dire plusieurs candidats des
différents partis de gauche se
présentent au premier tour et au second
on vote pour celui qui est arrivé en
tête c'est ça l'union de la gauche et
elle en Geoffroy je crois l'a rappelé à
plusieurs reprises et elle a raison
théoriquement raison après il y a
toujours eu deux grandes tendances une
guide Jaurès ça existait au sein du oui
mais là
c'est une tendance qui a accepté la loi
dominante de l'ultra gauche à savoir et
les filles la loi du plus fort aussi la
loi du plus fort exactement mais c'est
la première fois quand François
Mitterrand pratique l'union de la gauche
il accepte pas la loi du plus fort qui à
l'époque est-elle partie communiste je
vous le rappelle donc là il y a quelque
chose en effet où de la part d'Hélène
Geoffroy de la part du maire de Rouen il
y a une volonté un peu de revenir à
l'esprit originel d'une union de la
gauche qui respecte une diversité là il
y a pas eu diversité puisque dans à peu
près deux tiers des candidatures les
électeurs socialistes aux dernières
législatives ils étaient dans des tas de
régions en France ils cherchaient le
candidat socialiste très souvent puis
disait bah il y en a pas je suis obligé
de voter pour un candidat de la France
insoumise c'était ça le destin je vais
quand même demander à la jeune
socialiste que vous êtes déjà la charge
est lourde vous allez répondre mais
qu'est-ce qui fait quand on a 27 ans
l'avenir devant soi on reste au PS
aujourd'hui qui est quasiment voilà
presque plus d'adhérents j'en parlais il
y a quelques quelques jours avec des
camarades aussi qui sont un peu plus que
moi et qui m'ont demandé mais pourquoi
pourquoi tu es encore là moi j'ai adhéré
quand j'avais 16 ans au Parti socialiste
donc il y a un moment quelques années à
une époque où François Hollande était le
candidat pour devenir président de la
République est-ce que j'avais lu Jaurès
gay est-ce que je connaissais tout ces
débats absolument pas absolument pas je
suis venu au Parti socialiste parce que
c'était l'endroit utile pour faire
gagner la gauche face à la droite et moi
c'est ça que je comprends mais oui mais
je crois que vous êtes resté alors moi
je suis resté parce que justement j'ai
compris j'ai appris j'ai aussi vu que
c'était qu'un parti socialiste qui
pouvait changer les choses mais ce que
je dis aussi c'est que si j'avais 16 ans
aujourd'hui est-ce que je serais venu au
Parti socialiste je ne suis pas
convaincu cependant et ça je dois vous
le dire ce que vous dites que c'est pas
cette union de la gauche que c'est figé
etc mais moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que depuis juin depuis l'accord de
l'union de la gauche qu'apportait
Olivier Faure il y a plus de 2000
nouveaux adhérents au Parti socialiste
et plus de 1000 jeunes donc moi je veux
bien qu'on estime que tout ça est figé
que tout ça est très difficile mais moi
ce que je crois c'est que cet accord et
7 millions de la gauche qui a été faite
elle a soulevé en espoir dans le peuple
de gauche qui nous l'a demandé pendant
des mois sur le terrain et je trouve que
c'est beaucoup trop facile de balayer ça
d'un revers de main alors la mère et la
rage et puis j'irai vous voir Gaspard
ganter juste après comment vous
réagissez à cette idée d'un nouvel élan
au PS depuis l'alliance avec Mélenchon
depuis la nuit Pesse
est-ce que vous m'entendez il y a un
gros écho on va vous laisser répondre
mais s'il y a trop d'écho on va
peut-être essayer de baisser le son
allez-y et puis je vous dirai si ça
passe ou pas
je sais pas le constat que je fais moi
sur le terrain c'est pas le constat
qu'on fait à l'échelle du Parti
socialiste la preuve vous l'avez évoqué
on est plutôt dans un parti aujourd'hui
qui est en face de rabouissement qui est
en phase d'attrition on passe de 100.000
adhérents il y a tapas si longtemps que
ça aujourd'hui
22000 personnes qui viennent voter qui
se déplacent et qui viennent s'exprimer
on a eu des vagues massives on a eu un
premier secrétaire qui a dit à des
militants socialistes de partir s'il
n'était pas d'accord et surtout on a eu
cet accord de la nupestre qui s'est noué
à un moment qui était celui des
législatives dans le contexte électoral
qu'on connaissait post-présidentiel dans
le cadre d'un rapport de force qui était
établi certes ok est-ce que ça a permis
de gagner non est-ce que la gauche est
majoritaire aujourd'hui dans ce pays non
est-ce qu'il y a eu un bloc de gauche
qui a permis de créer une dynamique en
dehors de l'addition simple des voies de
chacune des écuries de gauche qui se
sont alliés dans le cadre de cet accord
non plus donc à partir de là ce que nous
disons avec Nicolas Mayer Rossignol
c'est qu'il faut pour avoir une
dynamique travailler renforcer le Parti
socialiste redonner des perspectives et
surtout mettre en oeuvre une méthode de
travail réouvrir les portes et les
fenêtres aussi pour faire revenir des
militants aux parties socialiste et
refaire vivre le débat d'idée c'est pas
ce qui s'est passé ces 5 dernières
années je pense que là c'est une
évidence Gaspard gonzer ou la carte vous
l'avez plus vous l'avez eu pendant très
longtemps nombreux années quand j'ai
décidé de m'éloigner après après 2017
pour aller faire d'autres choses dans ma
vie professionnelle notamment créer une
entreprise je dis pas la reprendre mais
peut-être qu'un jour je la reprendrai je
pense que beaucoup c'est intéressant
parce que vous le connaissez très bien
voilà ça a été un des très très proche
de François Hollande il a largué les
amarres il a il a rompu avec François
Hollande très clairement d'ailleurs il
le dit il dit il fallait que je me
libère pour enfin être de gauche est-ce
que c'est courageux de sa part d'avoir
créé la nuque selon vous c'est vrai
qu'il y a de nouveaux adhérents et puis
c'est une manière de surfaire survivre
des élus à l'Assemblée parce que sans la
nuque il y aurait peut-être 0 député
socialiste
de députés non plus c'est tout à fait
possible donc oui la Nupe a été utile
pour en fait sauver en fait l'essentiel
et à ce qu'un groupe parlementaire et de
ce point de vue là elle a été utile en
revanche une stratégie électorale ne
suffit pas à recréer de l'adhésion ce
qui est frappant dans ce dans ce congrès
c'est que contrairement au précédent on
a parlé que de tactiques on a peu parlé
d'un carnation c'est-à-dire de capacité
à diriger c'est-à-dire que moi il se
trouve qu'on est très bien plus les
trois candidats dont Nicolas Maya
Rossignol parce qu'on a travaillé
ensemble pour le refabus il y a quelques
années et les personnalités ne sont pas
tellement apparues pendant cette
campagne de congrès et surtout on n'a
pas parlé des idées c'est effectivement
incroyable qui est capable autour de ce
plateau à part peut-être vous bien
évidemment et l'ami elle arragent aussi
de dire quelles sont les différences
d'orientation sur le fond au-delà de
parfois du boogie-boulga qui peut
exister dans les mentions et ça c'est
pas nouveau c'est quoi les différences
fondamentales sur l'Europe sur
l'éducation sur le rapport à l'économie
sur la laïcité moi je crois que si le
Parti socialiste veut recréer de
l'adhésion ne fera pas sur une stratégie
électorale il ne fera pas probablement à
très court terme c'est une question de
rotation il le fera sur des propositions
du fond et une vision du monde c'est
comme ça qu'on crée de l'adhésion
pourquoi est-ce que certainement les
insoumis à un moment donné ont réussi à
créer de l'adhésion c'est parce que ils
ont travaillé un programme sur le fond
pendant très longtemps qui moi
personnellement je conteste mais qu'elle
mérite d'être clair ça a été pareil pour
Emmanuel Macron à un moment donné
certainement pour le rassemblement
national c'est les idées qui sauveront
le Parti socialiste et là on sera
nombreux et moi le premier à y retourner
dans ce cas-là on n'a pas travaillé
depuis très longtemps par tes socialiste
voyez pas d'idées oui rien venir de ce
côté là alors moi je leur enfournis
plein parce que en fin de compte j'étais
un peu la cour de récré pendant
longtemps pour les élus socialistes qui
venaient faire des voix invitées dans
mon dessin animé alors il y avait pas
que des socialistes mais il y avait
quand même un bon paquet d'entre eux
notamment dans silex and the City où il
y avait Najat Lascaux Belkacem il y
avait Arnaud Montebourg qui jouait un
singe en marinière comme ça et
prochainement François Hollande parce
que il a enregistré la voix du long
ouvrage silex and the City dont on
parlera sûrement mais et il fait c'est
son entrée comme personnage de cinéma
animé il est très bon donc tout le monde
se presse pour faire une voix et
incarner un personnage
c'est mieux que Rolex vous voyez avant
50 ans bon en tout cas vous avez voilà
trouver un moyen de recycler les
socialistes on va revenir sur les
résultats un instant donc Olivier fort
il a il est en tête c'est une évidence
la question c'est plus ou moins 50% pour
vous ça veut dire que c'est tranché sur
la ligne c'est c'est l'alliance avec
Mélenchon qui a gagné ce congrès c'est
pas l'alliance avec Mélenchon moi je
crois que ce qui a gagné c'est en tout
cas une ligne qui dit que le parc
socialiste doit redevenir de gauche vous
savez quand on était sur le terrain
pendant ces quelques années on souffrait
énormément du bilan et de ce que
certains retenait du bilan de François
Hollande c'est vrai on nous disait qu'on
avait trahi qu'on avait tourné le dos à
tout ça alors moi je ne dis pas que tout
était mauvais mais c'est vrai retourner
sur le terrain parce que certains
retenaient c'était le mariage pour tout
ce qui était évidemment très bien mais
aussi la loi travail et la déchéance de
nationalité on nous en parlait tous les
jours et moi ce que je sais c'est que
cet accord ce moment d'humilité aussi
politique qui a fait que beaucoup comme
moi d'ailleurs se sont retirés de leur
circonscriptions ou ils étaient
candidates ou candidats pour finalement
laisser la place à l'Union a fait
finalement à eu un énorme effet sur le
peuple de gauche qui s'est dit qu'on est
capable d'agir en une proposition de
gauche plus à gauche que ce qui aurait
été porté par le parti on va dire
social-démocrate qui a pu gouverner par
le passé nouvelle puisque vous avez eu
quand même quelques mois pour réfléchir
depuis la défaite d'Angelo dans notre
texte d'orientation qui s'appelle gagné
le texte qui est porté par Olivier Faure
on porte par exemple je crois le facteur
12 qui voudrait dire qu'on peur des
écarts de salaire maximum dans les
entreprises on porte aussi la question
du SMIC à 1600 euros on porte beaucoup
de choses notamment sur les questions
aussi de féminisme vous savez que le
Parti socialiste a mis en place par
exemple le congé menstruel aujourd'hui
dans le parti à l'image de ce fait par
le PSO et par Pedro Sanchez en Espagne
artiste socialiste je crois que pardon
oui c'est ça on porte beaucoup de choses
en termes de transformation et moi je
crois qu'on a déjà travaillé vous savez
je discutais avec Jérôme Guedj qui est
un député socialiste qui apporte en tant
que secrétaire national du Parti la
proposition de 100% sécu moi je crois
qu'on a beaucoup travaillé le problème
c'est que on ne nous entendait pas mais
on a porté des choses on a travaillé et
on a un bilan à toujours amener sur
notre terrain je crois que juste
maintenant on nous entend de nouveau
programme vous les voyez les
propositions le travail fourni l'un dans
les programmes on a l'impression que au
fond c'était pas ça qui était important
dans ce congrès que c'était que c'était
effectivement pour ou contre l'alliance
avec la nuque et la façon dont elle
s'est faite c'est un peu c'est ça qu'on
met en avant d'ailleurs les trois
candidats après sur ce que vous dites
sur le travail du PS on le voit on le
voit avec le les propositions de porte
les députés ça c'est vrai mais est-ce
que est-ce que à terme dans ce que vous
dites comment vous vous différencier
aussi des l'autre partie de la nuque
vous savez moi je pense que déjà
honnêtement être socialiste ça suppose
aussi une certaine solidité moi je me
sens pas fébrile quand je suis à côté
d'un jeune d'un jeune au fourmis ou d'un
jeune écolo ou d'un jeune communiste moi
je sais ce que je porte je porte
l'éducation comme une comme un chemin
essentiel vers l'émancipation je porte
la laïcité je porte
l'universalisme
en tout cas on a des projets de société
qui sont différents sinon on serait dans
le même parti et moi je pense que si on
est solide en tant que socialiste on est
capable de rester socialiste dans
l'Union et c'est ça que je porte mais je
pense que aujourd'hui et c'était un
détail que que on a peut-être trop
laissé de côté dans l'analyse très juste
que vous faisiez tout à l'heure sur
quelle était l'histoire de l'union de la
gauche aujourd'hui le risque c'est qu'en
2027 l'extrême droite gagne et moi je
suis désolé mais je suis d'une
génération qui n'a pas envie de voir
Marine Le Pen présidente de la
République
et c'est ça aujourd'hui mon obsession en
tant que militante c'est empêcher demain
que ce soit les réactionnaires les
racistes les antisémites qui gagnent
alors l'union de la gauche pour battre
l'extrême droite en 2027 on a bien
compris que c'était l'enjeu la
présidentielle qui était derrière ce
débat je vais vous ramener quand même un
instant à cette alliance avec Mélenchon
parce que on peut l'observer ici à
l'Assemblée nationale pour l'instant
elle tient avec quelques petites
fissures on voit cela dans Delta et avec
Stéphanie DESPER
démi-juillet première motion de censure
contre le gouvernement et première
fissure six députés PS ne votent pas la
motion pourtant déposer par toute la
nuque socialiste compris parmi ces
abstentionnistes l'ancienne patronne du
groupe à l'assemblée qui tente de
prendre ses distances avec la tactique
mélenchoniste du bruit et de la fureur
moi je fais pas partie de ceux qui
revendiquent le clash permanent et je
pense qu'en plus c'est pas la politique
doit de prendre un peu de
de hauteur ou de dignité sur l'Ukraine
sur les mesures de soutien au pouvoir
d'achat sur la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés le PS n'est pas
franchement aligné sur les insoumis à la
rentrée l'affaire cadenas ébranle la
nuque tout entière le député insoumis se
met provisoirement en retrait de la
santé mais pour les socialistes ça ne
suffit pas je pense on peut pas dans ces
conditions revenir sur les moments à
l'Assemblée au fil de l'automne
et des cartes
insoumise qui est de déposer
systématiquement d'émotions de censure à
chaque 49.3 parce que nous considérons
que ça participe de la banalisation de
cette motion censure et si on fait à
chaque fois d'émotions de censure on
devient prévisible mais alors pourquoi
vous la votez quand même pourquoi on l'a
voté parce que sur le fond il y avait
pas de raison enfin je veux dire on
partage les objectifs on veut dire nous
on est d'accord sur le fait que le texte
est pas bien que les méthodes est pas
bonne c'est juste que on estime que si
on le fait systématiquement on perd en
intérêt et finalement on finit par pu
nous écouter la première ministre elle
ne rate pas une occasion d'enfoncer un
coin entre les insoumis et leurs alliés
socialistes comme lors de cette
discussion sur l'antisémitisme personne
au sein de mon gouvernement n'a mis en
doute
Nami en doute
Nami en doute la position du groupe
socialiste du groupe communiste ou du
groupe Écologie Les Verts sur ces sujets
l'intention nous savons que vous êtes
des républicains et que vous défendez
comme nous la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme mais ça n'est pas le cas
de tout le monde sur ses bancs six mois
plus tard l'Union des socialistes avec
les troupes de Jean-Luc Mélenchon tient
encore bonhomme malin à l'inverse de
tous les autres partis de la nuque cette
semaine le Parti socialiste a voté la
loi sur les énergies renouvelables un
soutien décisif pour le gouvernement qui
réussit donc à faire adopter son texte
le patron des députés socialistes défend
sa singularité
une camisole nous pouvons et nous
faisons la démonstration que nous
pouvons être authentiquement dans une
union de la gauche nous parler
travailler ensemble prend des
initiatives communes comme hier soir un
meeting que nous avons fait avec
l'ensemble des forces de gauche et puis
être authentiquement pleinement
nous-mêmes et assumer quand on en a
avec les retraites la nuque espère
resserrer les rangs c'est tous contre le
gouv gouvernement mais à condition de ne
pas trop entrer dans les détails des
contre-propositions la partie socialiste
et France insoumise ne sont pas sur la
même longueur d'onde Lamia el rage si on
fait le bilan de cette alliance à
l'Assemblée alliance électorale mais
maintenant les groupes ils existent ils
coexistent à l'Assemblée on voit que le
Parti socialiste arrive à s'émanciper a
voter parfois même de façon différente
que les insoumis ça marche quand même
non
écoutez là aussi l'idée c'est pas de
jeter l'eau propre sur qui que ce soit
et encore une fois je crois que c'est
Emma qui le disait sur votre plateau la
question n'est pas celle de l'identité
socialiste moi je me sens pas menacée
par qui que ce soit dans la définition
que j'ai de mon rapport à mon parti ou
mon rapport à mon engagement militant
pour autant et vous le savez j'ai
défendu à l'Assemblée nationale la
vaccination obligatoire au moment de mon
groupe et je suis venu aussi porter
cette proposition sur votre plateau et
quand j'entends que dans la niche
parlementaire de la France insoumise
je vous propose la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés n'ont pas nous
socialistes mais la LFI Nuxe ce qui
ressort c'est que la nups défend la
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
évidemment que les socialistes ne la
défendent pas mais ça génère une forme
d'incompréhension vis-à-vis des
électeurs qui ne savent plus ce que
pensent le Parti socialiste par les
sujets qui sont vraiment très importants
et là on a deux lignes totalement
irré-conciliables et pourtant si je
comprends bien votre candidat Maya
Rossignol il veut de la nuque quand même
même s'il veut pas de cette nuque c'est
pas un peu Michel Michou quand on est
sur la vaccination sur des sujets aussi
graves est-ce que il faut pas tout
simplement divorcer de ce parti et
construire autre chose repartir de zéro
je pense pas que la question soit celle
d'un divorce ce soit celle de la remise
en cause de l'union de la gauche en fait
nous ce qu'on dit c'est très simple la
Nupe ça a été un accord électoral qui a
été passé à un momenté est-ce que ça
nous a permis de gagner non donc
maintenant nous devons construire une
union de la gauche avec les partis
politiques qui souhaitent travailler
avec nous mais aussi avec l'ensemble des
représentants de peuple de gauche qui
est engagé en politique mais pas la
politique partisane l'économie sociale
et solidaire les tout un ensemble
d'associations tout un ensemble de
bénévoles qui œuvrent au quotidien aux
côtés nos concitoyens et qui ont
vocation à porter avec nous un projet un
projet qu'on espère commun de façon à
lui donner de la force et de l'élan pour
les prochaines années il y a un autre
sujet si vous me permettez pour répondre
aussi à ce qui était dit tout à l'heure
sur votre plateau sur est-ce que le
Parti socialiste est audible clairement
non sinon je pense que nos scores
seraient légèrement sensible sans
différents lors des élections mais et
encore là c'est le féminisme du siècle
le vrai sujet je crois c'est si je vous
se poser la question donc quelle est la
position du Parti socialiste sur un
certain nombre de sujets vous ne
pourriez pas me répondre sur le
nucléaire sur la transition écologique
sur le rapport au travail même sur les
retraites qui est en cours d'examen à
l'Assemblée nationale nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui suffisamment travaillé dans
le cadre des instances et des
commissions qui sont celles du Parti
socialiste et c'est ça que nous
dénonçons aujourd'hui avec refondations
et avec un nombre très très important de
militants qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas fait
le choix de placer Olivier Faure
majoritaire dans ce partie parce qu'elle
perdrino qu'est-ce que vous inspire ces
échanges comment vous voyez l'avenir de
ce parti
l'avenir est difficile parce que déjà
vous avez un parti qui est en voie
d'attrition 40
000 militants ça n'est vraiment pas
grand chose un parti qui n'a plus
d'électeurs pour l'instant on verra si
il a une capacité dans la perspective
des prochaines européennes à se refaire
mais des prochaines européennes seules
ou avec ses partenaires qui ne partagent
à peu près rien pour l'instant c'est
plutôt ça puisque les écologistes ont
déjà dit que ils iraient seuls à cette
erreur
les européennes les maraphophytes moi je
pense qu'en tout cas les conditions ne
sont pas réunies pour faire une alliance
au moment des élections européennes vous
savez les on partage quand même sur
l'Europe
avec certains notamment les écologistes
sans doute une grande partie d'analyse
mais en tout cas c'est incompréhensible
pour les électeurs un coup oui pour les
législatives un coup nous pour une autre
élection c'est pour ça que je trouve que
ce débat de stratégie électorale il est
je reproche pas qu'on le fasse ici mais
finalement c'est déjà un débat du passé
je pense que
principe à la portée ses effets au
moment de l'élection législative elle a
permis de sauvegarder des groupes
parlementaires mais on sait bien que il
y aura pas d'alliance aux élections
européennes ira de son côté causes
élections locales ça sera comme
d'habitude il y aura pas de liste
commune il y aura des rassemblements au
deuxième tour dès le premier tour on
verra mais bon
oui mais pas avec les verres par exemple
avec les insoumis dans la majorité dès
le premier tour il y aura des
configurations locales très différentes
de région en région de départements et
de ville en ville et donc ça sera comme
d'habitude et à l'élection
présidentielle je pense que la plupart
des socialistes des écologistes
n'accepteront pas la Nupe s'il s'agit de
se soumettre à Jean-Luc Mélenchon moi je
l'ai écouté hier soir alors justement
hier soir
je suis remplaçable évidemment et je le
souhaite est-ce que vous êtes remplacé
attendez et je le souhaite je ne suis
pas candidat à ma succession vous ne
serez pas candidat quoi qu'il arrive en
2027 vous voulez que je vous signale un
papier et si jamais je mets le moindre
doute
bon
parlons-en puisque ça a l'air d'obséder
je ne sais combien de gens
c'est pas clair c'est ça peut pas se
régler comme ça ce sont les
circonstances qui font les candidatures
tout le monde le sait voilà la petite
phrase ce sont les circonstances qui
font les candidatures
a envie d'être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en 2027 et de dans ce
cadre-là la question qui est posée
partie socialiste et si Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et candidat à l'élection
présidentielle est-ce que le Parti
socialiste le soutien tour et moi à
titre personnel n'étant pas grand du
Parti socialiste mais étant de gauche je
refuse totalement cette configuration et
marafaite moi je pense qu'il faut sortir
des postures honnêtement sortir des
postures moi j'entends beaucoup de
postures dans ce que dans ce que
j'entends vous savez moi je pense pense
que l'arrêter c'est que le débat au
Parti socialiste qu'on a en ce moment il
n'aurait pas lieu si certains des déçus
de la nupes qui n'avaient pas eu leur
circonscription ou qu'il l'avait eu
finalement s'il l'avait eu leur
circonscription se débat n'aurait pas
lieu non mais là je crois aussi
et je crois aussi qu'est-ce que vous
faites il y a notamment beaucoup de
membres de la direction nationale qui
aujourd'hui s'y oppose alors qu'ils en
sont comptables également vous savez moi
je pense que oui il faut se battre pour
une candidature unique de la gauche en
2027 ce que je pense par contre c'est
que moi ce que je pense c'est que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'est pas le meilleur
pour faire gagner la gauche en 2027 je
le pense cependant en 2022 lors du
premier tour des élections
présidentielles je crois qu'il a été
placé en tête maintenant la question
pour nous socialistes
c'est pas tellement est-ce que moi
personnellement je pense que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est le meilleur je ne le pense
pas je suis socialiste la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à convaincre
les électrices et les électeurs parce
que là nous avons un débat d'initié mais
le débat il se passe sur le terrain il
se passe ensuite dans les urnes et donc
là il a mon combat c'est un combat pour
le mouvement c'est un combat pour le
socialisme et je crois qu'on ne réussira
pas à le régler uniquement par des
postures sur des plateaux qui consiste à
dire finalement l'Union oui avec
celui-là l'Union non avec celui-là il
faut travailler pour ensuite créer des
conditions de gagner
je suis évidemment d'accord sur le
principe mais le problème c'est que dans
la vraie vie Jean-Luc Mélenchon écrase
le débat public à gauche et en fait tant
qu'il est là il est impossible de se
faire entendre c'est ce que ce qui était
dit tout à l'heure par la bielle RH ce
qui était dit aussi c'est le problème
c'est qu'il a pris l'ascendant
psychologique qu'on le veille ou non et
donc tant qu'on sera dans son équipe ça
sera lui le Capitaine on montrait à
l'instant à l'instant dans votre
chronique que les socialistes ont réussi
à se différencier vous le savez moi avec
les jeunes socialistes depuis le début
on a appelé à la démission de Monsieur
catenans depuis le début on a dit tout
ça et aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe
les jeunes insoumis par centaines nous
rejoignent dans
nos
voilà d'ailleurs y compris chez les
insoumis la guerre de succession a
commencé il y en a beaucoup qui ne se
représente pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon il a
il a évidemment pas fermé la question
hier soir mais d'un point de vue quand
même politique si la gauche vous gagnez
il va falloir quand même qu'elle se
rassemblent dès le premier tour non oui
qu'elle se rassemble tout est dans les
modalités du rassemblement vous avez vu
qu'il y a plusieurs modalités de
rassemblement et Jean-Luc Mélenchon une
primaire de toute la gauche c'est
envisageable pour ne pas ramasser les
miettes il faut exister avant le
problème c'est que le Parti socialiste
on peut s'enriser c'est qu'il n'existe
pas vraiment aux yeux de l'immense
majorité des français et même de ce
qu'on appelait jadis le peuple de gauche
qui est disséminé partout et même un peu
aujourd'hui en dehors de la gauche mais
il faut bien que si vous voulez le Parti
socialiste
partialiste à tout mettez le pivot de la
gauche ou la Cinquième République ça a
été quoi ça a été la gauche de
gouvernement faut pas qu'elle l'oublie
ça et cette gauche de gouvernement elle
est en train de flirter avec une gauche
qui n'est pas une gauche de gouvernement
vous allez nous expliquer que je spa
n'était pas de gauche comme n'était pas
de gauche
il faut le retenir nous avons déçu nous
avons fait 6 pour gagner 2017 6% en 2017
attendez je crois que cette notion de
gauche de gouvernement c'est extrêmement
importante on le voit si vous voulez à
droite avec ce qui reste de la droite de
gouvernement qui tente aujourd'hui de se
reconstruire autour de la notion nous
sommes une force de gouvernement nous
nous considérons par exemple que sur la
réforme des retraites et bien faut
frotter avec la majorité puisque on
reprend l'essentiel de notre message
d'ailleurs vous voyez le problème c'est
que le Parti socialiste n'est pas
lisible parce qu'il fait un pas en avant
un pas en arrière mais hier il a fait un
pas en avant dans cette ligne en disant
par exemple sur le terrain de l'écologie
et bien on va voter avec le gouvernement
pour envoyer un petit signal tout de
même à dans les énergies renouvelables
une force de gouvernement et nous ne
sommes pas simplement une force de
protestation pour faire aussi son
attitude dans le débat sur les retraites
parce que pour l'instant il s'aligne
quelque peu surélés les filles et donc
il est dans une démarche complètement
protestataire on se demande même si le
Parti socialiste se souvient qu'il y a
eu la réforme Touraine voilà s'en
souvient tout simplement pour l'instant
d'après le programme c'est c'est le
retour à 60 ans marine et Bénédicte
Teller vous aurez le mot de la fin oui
c'est vrai que pour l'instant on ne sait
pas où est le Parti socialiste sur la
réforme des retraites ça c'est un gros
sujet et c'est une grosse question
est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'il est encore sur
les 62 ans et les 43 annuités ou est-ce
qu'il est sur les 60 ans et les 40 admis
vous le voyez dans les années qui
viennent se reconstruire travailler sur
le fond et reprendre une forme de
leadership sur la gauche ou c'est
franchement pas pour ce coup-là il
faudra peut-être encore
la semaine de notre sémiologue Mariette
darrigan c'est le mot pénibilité
retraite oblige à tout à l'heure les
amis c'est votre quart d'heure Jules on
y vient rentrer feu d'artifice l'arche
de Rantanplan c'est le nouvel opus de
Lucky Luke et puis aussi une épopée sans
images on va en parler c'est un roman
feuilleton au seuil et la troisième
saison de 50 nuances de Grey ça fait
beaucoup vous nous disiez qu'il y avait
aussi un film bientôt il y a le long
métrage silex and the City ayant il y a
même un truc aussi qui est mon premier
Spirou non et ouais j'ai fait un album
de Spirou
ça fait beaucoup pour un seul homme on
en parle juste après l'invitation
saigner Marco pommier
si on vous invite Jules c'est pour avoir
votre regard sur l'époque que nous
vivons comment choisir les mots pour
qualifier notre temps pour mieux
apprendre à naviguer dans ces moments
tourmentés en ce qui nous concerne et
nous revient d'affronter ce nouveau
chapitre d'une rue d'époque alors bien
sûr Jules impossible de vous inviter
sans parler de l'homme qui tire plus
vite que son ombre depuis 2016 vous êtes
le scénariste en chef de Lucky Luke ce
héros de BD à temporel
un petit bisou à dans l'arche de
Rantanplan 82e album de la saga le
cowboy part à la conquête d'un Far West
devenu vegan comme un écho aux questions
et fractures actuelles de notre société
[Musique]
Jules derrière votre crayon affûté il y
a d'abord un intello après Normal Sup
l'agrégation et une courte expérience de
professeur d'histoire chinoise vous vous
faites un nom dans le dessin de presse
dans les plus grands médias l'humanité
Marianne ou Charlie Hebdo mais la
révélation s'est en 2005 énorme succès
avec votre première bande dessinée il
faut tuer José Bové l'occasion de
railler les travers des
altermondialistes jamais méchant
toujours juste et drôle je suis
dessinateur et scénariste et moi j'aime
bien mettre beaucoup de références plus
on est ouvert et puis on est vaste plus
on a de chances d'inventer des trucs
variés la BD un véritable terrain
d'expression votre marque de fabrique
l'anachronisme puisé dans le passé pour
mieux raconter le présent comme dans
silex on the City ou 50 nuances de Grecs
où vous mêlez les héros de la mythologie
à notre actualité crise écologique
addiction aux écrans
mais aussi le mouvement Mitou on est mal
les mecs il y a des déesses qui viennent
de lancer un hashtag pour dénoncer les
violences sexuelles dans la mythologie
balance ton pan encore un truc du hétéro
alors Jules ce soir on a une question
pour vous quel est le mot juste pour
caractériser notre époque
tiens voilà une bonne question vous
l'aimez déjà notre époque ou pas
je m'en a commode mais moi je suis un
grand nostalgique donc c'est pour ça
aussi que j'ai travaillé dans la
recherche en histoire avant de faire de
la bande dessinée je suis un petit peu
comme le idfix dans la série c'est avec
un arbre qui a arraché il pleure voilà
bref finalement je suis un attachement
au passé et ce qui existe et à chaque
fois que les choses disparaissent ça me
fait toujours un petit pincement
évidemment
on a l'impression que c'est une manière
quand même de plonger dans dans le passé
regardez tous ces mythes grecs mais même
rente en plan même l'arche d'orant il y
a un cadre allez prenons Lucky Luke pour
commencer
quatrième album là vous le mettez chez
les véganes c'est vraiment lui qui Luke
au Far West des végan et là on est à la
fois dans quelque chose de très très
politique mais en même temps avec un
énorme recul vous vous moquez un peu de
vous-même vous vous moquez du personnage
mais il y a un cadre comment on fait
pour faire un album de Lucky Luke c'est
cette distance là qui est intéressante
parce que j'ai commencé comme
dessinateur de presse donc j'avais le
nez collé à l'actualité un petit peu
comme vous à chaque fois qu'il se
passait un truc bah je devais sortir un
commentaire puis j'en ai eu assez un
petit peu de qu'on me dicte cet agenda
et en même temps ce qui m'intéressait
c'était quand même aujourd'hui et
finalement avec cette transposition dans
le passé la préhistoire si l'excent the
city 50 nuances de Grey quantité et ce
19e siècle américain aussi mythique qui
est le cadre de Lucky Luke ça permet de
parler d'énormément de choses
d'aujourd'hui et finalement de
rembobiner des comprendre où sans
racines les questions et c'est estomper
il y a une liberté totale de choix
comment vous faites parce que c'est
quand même voilà c'est une institution
il y a toujours HD au dessin c'est vous
qui choisissez où il y a une presque 10
ans que j'ai repris Lucky Luke et on à
chaque projet que j'ai proposé ça a été
toujours voilà un enthousiasme du côté
de l'éditeur des ayants droits de Lucky
Luke qui veillent au grain d'une
certaine façon il y avait eu Lucky Luke
et les Juifs la terre promise
un cow-boy dans le coton c'était pour la
première fois des Noirs comme personnage
principaux dans Lucky Luke la question
de l'esclavage la question raciale
c'était assez transgressif je dirais
pour un Lucky Luke et puis là on
s'aventure sur des terrains finalement
qui est la question de la maltraitance
animale la chasse les véganes et une
forme de radicalité aussi le l'action
aujourd'hui donc on arrive à relire un
petit peu notre époque contemporaine
très très actuelle où c'est des débats
sont très très incandescents en même
temps en voyant où est-ce que ça prend
racine parce que en fait c'est à
l'époque de Lucky Luke que la première
Spa a été fondée qu'on sait qu'on a
réfléchi sur ces questions et on le sait
pas donc avec finalement
en temps le chien le plus bête de
l'Ouest c'est toujours assez utile et
moi ce que j'aime bien c'est s'il y a
pas vraiment de parti pris un peu près
chiffréchal dans les albums que je fais
que ce soit Lucky Luke ou les autres ça
met en scène les différents
protagonistes d'un même débat donc ce
débat autour de la condition animale bah
on le voit à la table du déjeuner le
week-end en famille le vieux grand-père
qui va à chasser la fille qui est vegan
radicale ça s'engueule autour de la
table de la même façon les différents
personnages dans celui qui Luke ont une
parole apportée sur toutes ces questions
c'est ça qui est génial c'est justement
de mêler tous ces mondes vous le faites
parfaitement avec les mites grecques
faut dire que voilà vous vous les
connaissez vous plongez il y a un nombre
d'histoires pas possible on va regarder
quelques quelques visages vous par
exemple on voyait Zeus tout à l'heure
Zeus dans 50 nuances de Grey c'est
Philippe Torreton oui voilà alors tous
les gens qui viennent prêter leur voix
au personnage sont assez sont assez
rigolos et ça donne
quand il est quand il devient barbu ils
sont pas tous comme eux mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a beaucoup de journalistes il y
a beaucoup de gens qui viennent aussi
d'autres univers des chanteurs j'étais
hyper Stéphane par exemple faire mais
alors le truc le plus marrant je crois
de cette nouvelle saison c'est que
Enrico Macias joue Pythagore et alors là
c'est extraordinaire parce qu'il a son
accent inimitable et il se retrouve à
enseigner les les mathématiques de Dieu
Grecs qui sont archi nul à l'école
la très belle actrice c'est Orphée et
vous avez mis Augustin Trapenard joue
Jésus
alors ça c'est très très drôle et lui
ressemble c'est incroyable en fait on
l'a designé comme Augustin Trapenard
évidemment et c'était assez marrant
parce que lui il va en stage en fait
dans l'Olympe il va chez les
polythéistes pour voir un petit peu
comment ça se passe
pour grec sont-ils si
forts turges pour pour nous raconter
nous synthétisé des grands fondamentaux
de notre civilisation et finalement le
vernis judéo-chrétien un petit peu
coincé est venu par-dessus mais je veux
dire les grandes questions
philosophiques que ce soit dans la vie
quotidienne les histoires de couple de
famille les trahisons et toutes ces
choses qui aujourd'hui font la une des
journaux aussi l'inceste le la violence
faite aux femmes le harcèlement des
choses comme ça c'est la toile de fond
perpétuel de toute cette mythologie
voilà c'est ce génie extraordinaire
c'est pas un dieu c'est pas un héros
mais c'est un mec qui est Smart et il
nous ressemble parce que il a le goût de
la découverte de l'invention mais à
chaque fois qu'il fait quelque chose ça
crée une catastrophe et donc windo créer
une deuxième invention pour réparer la
catastrophe précédente et notre course à
la technologie aujourd'hui quand on voit
voilà les questions de climat les
questions d'énergie on essaye de à
chaque fois avoir une réponse
technologique mais ça déclenche quelque
chose de pire c'est une course à l'abîme
que les Grecs avaient déjà hyper bien
compris alors ce qui est incroyable
c'est que moi je vous connais depuis
longtemps on va le dire au
téléspectateurs
n'hésitez pas vous avez une tête bien
faite vous êtes normaliens vous êtes
agrégé d'histoire vous êtes sinologue
vous êtes parlez plusieurs langues et
puis vous dessinez mais vous dessinez
depuis l'enfance sans germer vraiment
avoir été dans des écoles de dessert et
puis quoi à 18 20 ans un peu plus tard
même vous vous lancez vous vous décidez
d'en faire votre carrière alors que
toutes les autres portes sont ouvertes
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on s'autorise
la raison il y a une personne pour
lequel qui à qui je dois finalement le
fait d'être dessinateur comme métier
c'est-à-dire que je faisais de la
recherche en histoire chinoise et
j'étais inscrit à le Hass l'École des
hautes études en sciences sociales et je
devais je voulais partir à Taïwan
étudier le chinois classique des grandes
formations de chinois classiques un peu
comme le latin par rapport à nos langues
et en fait le chargé des études de cette
école a dit non pas question il faut
passer des exams il faut être en
présentiel ça sais pas ce mot à l'époque
à Paris on sait engueuler au téléphone
vraiment je trouvais que c'était
vraiment beaucoup trop administratif et
classique j'ai raccroché furieux et j'ai
dit je démissionne j'arrête la recherche
l'éducation nationale et cette personne
que j'avais eu au bout du fils avait pas
peine non et oui donc c'est une bonne
histoire
et je vais raconter par la suite donc je
lui dois beaucoup finalement en manque
un avec lui au téléphone c'est ça qui a
fait que je me suis mis à dessiner
par Charlie Hebdo
vous avez été comme beaucoup d'entre
nous traumatisés mais vraiment aussi
voilà vous connaissiez très
personnellement les dessinateurs qui ont
été assassinés pendant les attentats
vous êtes en lien avec Charlie
aujourd'hui toujours Charlie
il y a toute une équipe nouvelle que je
connais absolument pas et puis des gens
de l'ancien Charlie qui reste et avec
qui je suis plus ou moins en lien
beaucoup de gens parmi mes amis sont des
gens qui ont quitté un peu Charlie qui
ont fait une autre carrière Catherine
Meurice Luz qui aujourd'hui font leurs
albums de bande dessinée une récente de
char sur les mots là ça le mérite de la
constance je dirais et ensuite c'est
vrai que ces questions moi je suis un
peu loin de l'actu mais malgré tout je
peux pas ne pas m'en parler et je le
mets aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
Instagram des choses comme ça de des
sujets que ce soit l'Ukraine ou l'Iran
omniprésents finalement dans la tête de
beaucoup d'entre nous sur les rangs qui
est important quand même à garder vivant
en permanence et il y a une forme de
dignité malgré tout de l'humour et de
l'humour politique et de ce côté
grinçant face à je dirais le le
renoncement devant la fatalité on peut
dire un auteur engagé vous adorez ne pas
vous prendre au sérieux il y a beaucoup
de détournement d'autodérision dans
toutes vos BD dans tous vos livres et en
même temps on se souvient alors ça fait
un moment déjà mais cette fameuse photo
avec Emmanuel Macron avec ce t-shirt LBD
c'était à c'était à Angoulême oui alors
là la prochaine festival d'Angoulême qui
arrive à traiter
2020 à l'époque où ça a failli provoquer
un incident ma
vous gardez quel sentiment de ce
moment-là moi j'ai une espèce j'ai un
cause une forme d'espier glorie
naturelle c'est-à-dire que quand on dit
de pas faire quelque chose j'ai envie de
le faire et en même temps j'ai aussi un
côté respect pour les institutions pour
les fonctions républicaines ça me paraît
important donc voilà je suis toujours le
cul entre deux chaises ça me ressemble
finalement mais c'est vrai que je pense
que l'esprit hiérarchique l'esprit de
sérieux et puis je dirais cette espèce
de d'omniprésence des slogans de la
pensée prémâchée des communicants
politiques me hérissent tellement
évidemment j'ai toujours envie voilà
réussir à avoir une photo du président
avec le t-shirt c'est lui qui a suscité
cette photo l'histoire était absurde ça
c'est vraiment un syndrome Macron c'est
à dire c'est encore son espèce de
syndrome permanent du Loto sabotage et
puis après il rattrape derrière lui
c'est dédale il est complètement dans le
syndrome
je pense qu'il va réfléchir tu nous
écoutes pour Jupiter mais en fait c'est
dédale merci beaucoup Jules Angoulême
qui commence quoi dans deux semaines
évidemment avec Spirou non je t'ai plus
hein quelle rentrée et puis vous
travaillez sur quoi aujourd'hui le
prochain qu'il faut déjà un peu commencé
à que à lire et à ruminer je crois que
j'ai un très bon thème il y a deux ans
entre chaque album donc là ça y est je
rentre dans l'écriture la recherche
rendez-vous dans deux ans
on saura pas vous restez avec moi tous
les cas c'est l'heure d'accueillir comme
le programme du PS ouais il est vraiment
très très enfui celui-là allez on va
accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris elles sont trois on les
accueille tout de suite allez-y
on termine avec trois femmes se ce
vendredi Mariette Dary grand pour son
mot de la semaine pénibilité on va y
venir dans un instant et puis epchtel de
Libération les villes de demain va-t-on
enfin en finir avec la France moche vous
ne direz tout ça mais on commence avec
l'histoire du jour comme chaque soir
Bourbon Express cette histoire c'est
vous qui nous la racontez elle va oui
alors ce soir Myriam je vais pas vous
raconter d'histoires je vais plutôt vous
poser une question est-ce que vous êtes
plutôt 49,3 ou 47 1 là je dirais 49 3
mais non je sais alors on est vendredi
13 vous pourriez croire que c'est le
tirage du Loto pas du tout moi je vous
parle arctique de la Constitution c'est
très sérieux on va rentrer dans une zone
très technique mais vous allez le voir
sur cette réforme des retraites il y a
le fond qui compte évidemment mais il y
a aussi la forme la mécanique
parlementaire elle est importante alors
on le rappelle pour faire passer cette
réforme le gouvernement il a choisi de
passer par un projet de loi de finances
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
accrochez-vous pour le sigle ça va
donner soit PLFR SS soit
plfssr alors pourquoi c'est affreux
voilà donc dans tous les cas on essaiera
de redire pour bien le réexpliquer
pourquoi le gouvernement a choisi ce
véhicule législatif parce qu'il y avait
deux avantages déjà sur un texte
budgétaire le gouvernement peut recourir
à l'article 49 alinéa 3 sur les budgets
c'est autant qu'il le veut alors que sur
les textes classiques c'est une fois par
session le 49-300 le commence à bien le
connaître ici à l'Assemblée Elisabeth
borne elle l'a utilisé déjà 10 fois
depuis le mois d'octobre mais si le
gouvernement l'utilise là cette fois ce
sera pas du tout la même chose puisque
c'est le porte-parole du gouvernement
qui nous l'explique ce matin il y a le
bon 49-3 et il y a le mauvais 49-3
le mauvais 49-3 c'est quand vous n'avez
pas de majorité absolue et que vous êtes
obligé d'actionner ce dispositif
constitutionnel pour faire adopter un
texte le bon 49.3 c'est quand vous avez
une obstruction au Parlement manifeste
alors que vous disposez d'une majorité
absolue et ce qui permet d'adopter le
texte et avancer le pays
le bon et le mauvais chasseur voici donc
le bon et le mauvais 49,3 bon en fait il
y a une carte maîtresse vous allez nous
expliquer ça c'est pas le 49-3 ce sont
les délais constitutionnels oui
puisqu'evidemment le gouvernement a bien
conscience que faire passer une réforme
des retraites à coup de 49-3 ça
risquerait de crispé les oppositions
mais l'opinion publique en général dans
l'autre atout du gouvernement vous
l'avez dit Myriam ce sont les délais
constitutionnels c'est dans le règlement
où il y a la Constitution aussi article
47-1 retenez bien ce nouvel article qui
stipule donc que si l'Assemblée
nationale ne s'est pas prononcée en
première lecture dans le délai de 20
jours après le dépôt d'un texte et bah
hop le gouvernement ces il Sénat qui
doit statuer lui dans un délai de 15
jours
terre au bout de 20 jours textes fini ou
non ce sera au Sénat plus de discussions
à l'Assemblée ça les opposition
évidemment sont sur rendu compte et ça
les iris réécouter l'écologie Sophie
Tallier polluence et lors de la séance
de questions gouvernement mardi dernier
vous choisissez cette option uniquement
pour limiter le débat parlementaire
cette procédure ouvre même la
possibilité de passer par ordonnance en
cas dans l'ismant alors on pensait
qu'après 10 49-3 on avait tout vu bien
non l'innovation au pouvoir avec vous
décidément vous êtes très fort c'est un
véritable détournement de l'esprit de la
Constitution renoncer à cette méthode
renoncer à cette réforme alors pour
compliquer encore un peu le tout il y a
même des discussions entre juristes pour
savoir si ces délays peuvent bien
s'appliquer dans ce cas là le
gouvernement en tout cas a l'air très
très sûr de lui ça n'empêchera pas les
oppositions de saisir le Constitutionnel
le Conseil constitutionnel à la fin de
l'examen du texte mais ça c'est pas pour
tout de suite entre temps j'ai encore le
temps de vous raconter beaucoup
d'histoires merci merci Elsa vous
regardez un peu de la vie à l'Assemblée
ça vous inspire Jules
peut-être mais là ça c'est
autorisé je sais je sais je sais mais il
faut il y en a qui font le job très bien
donc je leur en sais genre c'est
vraiment gré allez on va continuer à
parler retraite avec vous Mariette comme
chaque semaine vous choisissez un mot
dans l'actualité et ce mot ce soir c'est
pénibilité oui c'est un mot qui a été
vraiment beaucoup prononcé cette semaine
je me suis demandé pourquoi finalement
mais je crois que c'est parce que il
fait l'unanimité on peut être pour ou
contre les régimes spéciaux pour ou
contre la revalorisation des petites
pensions mais qui voudrait que la peine
des travailleurs soit augmentée parce
que derrière péniliser c'est peine un
très vieux mot un mot des yeux
d'ailleurs je me suis amusé j'ai entendu
beaucoup parler de la de ce nouveau
studio de tout le travail que ça
demandait à l'équipe et j'ai entendu on
a bossé comme des fous etc mais je n'ai
pas entendu on s'est donné de la peine
pourtant c'était bien c'était bien ça
donc ce mot est désespéré il revient à
un mot antique la peau est na la peau
est né en grec ou en latin qui voulait
dire en fait la somme d'argent que l'on
devait l'amende en quelque sorte quand
on avait fait une mauvaise action donc
c'est ça qu'il faut garder en tête
sentir un prix à payer quand on dit
pénibilité aujourd'hui dans cette
réforme des retraites ça veut dire qu'on
dit aussi qu'il y a un prix à payer il y
a un coût quoi il y a un coup parce que
finalement les gens payent quand on a un
emploi quand on a la chance de faire une
carrière on voit bien qu'une sorte de
contre salaire on paye on mal de dos en
stress en burn out
éventuellement suicide de plus en plus
nombreux sur les lieux de travail donc
tout ça est très très courant
malheureusement aujourd'hui on
développements et pourtant la pénibilité
telle qu'on la raconte tel qu'on la
parle elle reste purement physique elle
est pas du tout mentale j'ai vraiment
écouté attentivement cette semaine ce
qui c'est les exemples par exemple qui
étaient donnés bon ici même on était
question des déménageurs
on a les aides-soignantes qui soulèvent
des gens très lourds toute la journée
des gens qui travaillent dans des
abattoirs donc c'est toujours une peine
physique mais mais jamais psychique
c'est ça jamais psychique or si vous
voulez c'est très injuste parce que ces
connotations elle nous rend une forme
d'oubliée en fait il y a un oubli elle
nous ramène à germinal disons plutôt que
au nouveau métier à la école d'aller et
chez nous bien sûr tous les moitié de la
tech du virtuel qui sont à creuser de la
souffrance au travail donc ça c'est le
développement de la partie mentale du
mot Pen quand on dit il nous même j'ai
de la peine quand un enfant dit j'ai la
peine ou quand quelqu'un qui est très
déprimé dit ma vie ne vaut pas la peine
donc il faut vraiment un nouveau mot il
faudrait trouver un mot justement pour
alors l'installer dans le débat
peut-être qu'il faut trouver un nouveau
mot parce que celui-là est très désuet
et on emploie plus tellement dans la vie
courante mais en tout cas je crois que
l'oubli de la part des syndicats des
politiques et tout à fait coupable
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment pas possible
il faut vraiment que je pense que c'est
le préjugé qu'ils ont c'est trop bobo
c'est trop etc mais non le travail a
changé le travail à muté donc la
pénibilité ne doit pas rester purement
physique puis en plus je crois que c'est
un peu
idiot de leur part parce qu'il devrait y
voir dans cette nouvelle pénibilité en
quelque sorte un nouveau marché si on
peut parler comme ça et en tout cas
c'est peut-être mon petit conseil pour
finir mais ce serait que leur propre ils
sont à la peine les syndic recruter pour
mobiliser or s'ils s'intéressait
vraiment sincèrement à cette question
s'il prenait la peine de regarder à fond
je crois que leur propre pénibilité à
remplir leur fonction ben serait soulevé
serait alléger la peine
le pénibilité
je crois c'est plus important
alors Eve ce soir je rappelle que vous
vous avez la rubrique sur les villes sur
l'urbanisme au sein du quotidien
Libération vous vouliez attirer notre
attention sur
une volonté du gouvernement de refaire
un tout petit peu l'entrée des villes
parce que qu'est-ce que c'est moche il
faut bien se le dire alors c'est une
nouvelle qui est passé totalement
inaperçue mais en décembre le
gouvernement a décidé de s'attaquer à la
France moche alors vous voyez ce que
c'est la fronde moche c'est ses entrées
de ville à peu près tous les mêmes alors
on a des bataillons de panneaux
publicitaires des enfilades de
rond-point avec de part et d'autre de la
route des comme des boîtes à chaussures
on a des entrepôts des réseaux
industriels du parking Intermarché etc
et c'est souvent en fait la première
vision qu'on a d'une ville en fait quand
on arrive même une belle ville Chartres
Limoges 7 à chaque fois c'est ça et puis
longtemps il y a une sorte de fatalisme
qui régnait on se disait bon il faut
s'incliner devant la modernité il faut
prendre acte de ce chaos en quelque
sorte naturel et puis c'est aussi le
prix à payer de la croissance finalement
et de notre confort matériel toutes ces
enseignes de bricolage etc c'est l'État
qui est derrière ça non oui d'une
certaine façon toutes les entrées des
villes à célèbres oui qui a créé cette
France moche à coup de jus puis de Zac
comme on a appelé etc zone d'aménagement
concerté mais la bonne nouvelle c'est ce
que l'État a fait il peut aujourd'hui le
défaire et justement il a décidé en
décembre donc de lancer la deuxième
phase d'un programme qu'on appelle
action cœur de ville qui est doté de 5
milliards il va avoir deux nouveaux 5
milliards alors c'est un programme un
plan d'aménagement du territoire
nouvelle façon voulue par Emmanuel
Macron dès 2017 dès son arrivée au
pouvoir pour revitaliser les villes
moyennes donc c'est les villes entre
20000 et 100 000 habitants
qui voilà souffre de vacances
commerciales de logement dans le
centre-ville un salut etc le constat de
Macron qu'il a fait avant les gilets par
contre c'est que il faut s'occuper de
cette France là c'est quand même un
quart de la population
qui est frappé par la
désindustrialisation et aussi par par un
sentiment de relégation très fort par
rapport à la France des métropoles donc
ce constat il est fait il était
d'ailleurs fait donc avant les gilets
jaunes c'est ça veut dire
ça a vraiment renforcé le président dans
sa conviction il a dit il a dit les
Français ils en ont rien à faire
finalement des débats sur l'identité
nationale ce qu'ils veulent c'est
retrouver le contrôle et la possession
de leur vie et de leur ville et de leur
paysage aussi mais on peut et donc que
ce sera fini cette France moche alors
oui ça va prendre du temps les préfets
ils ont reçu instruction de suspendre
les projets d'ouverture de surface
commerciale en périphérie pour éviter de
concurrencer le commerce de centre-ville
et on a incité les élus à s'emparer des
outils juridiques qui ont été créés
exprès pour voilà leur faciliter la
tâche et restructurer ses entrées de
ville et alors certains ont déjà sont
déjà au travail ce sont pas la peine de
de d'y réfléchir à Chartres le maire a
carrément décidé de déplacer la zone
commerciale de 200 mètres pour dégager
en fait la perspective et donc et la
reconstruire plus loin donc et imaginez
Myriam que d'ici quelques années on sera
quand on arrivera à Chartres dans nos
voitures électriques et parce qu'on
verra en premier ça sera pas Décathlon
Ikea noir auto ou ça sera la flèche de
la cathédrale Notre-Dame
exactement on peut se le souhaiter parce
que vous vous déplacez beaucoup en
France vous la trouvez moche cette
entrée de ville les ronds-points les
entrepôts mais j'ai l'impression enfin
je soupçonne je savais pas cette
histoire mais je pense que en fait ils
vont rendre moche l'intérieur des villes
du coup qui était
déserts et là ça va être rempli et moche
parce que en fait il va y avoir genre la
même rue piétonne merdique avec un
camaïeu une brioche dorée machin et
toutes les franchises qu'il y a et
toutes les rues piétonnes identiques
dans toutes les villes de France
les chaussures de l'extérieur donc en
fait c'est juste horrible tout le temps
allez on est en retard je suis obligé
merci beaucoup merci Jules excellent
grand témoin ce soir merci les
affranchis Elsa a très vite merci aussi
je voulais le dire je sais que j'ai peu
de temps à David montagne le chef
d'orchestre de ce nouveau studio qui
nous a accompagné toute la semaine la
production évidemment la régie la
rédaction bien sûr et puis l'équipe
l'équipe de savon regarde je peux pas
citer tout le monde alors excellent
weekend profitez bien et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]